hello front my name is reto meier and
welcome to this week in Android
development for October 15 2012 this
week's challenge for regular viewers
figure out which of these shots are live
and which are green screened last week
in Android development we celebrate a
tablet week by releasing new promotional
sections in Google Play to highlight
great tablet apps developers can check
out the Android developer blog to learn
more about building quality tableau apps
if you want to skip the unwrapping and
jump straight to the juicy marrow check
out the tablet app quality checklist to
feed on the knowledge of what it takes
to build an app that's designed for the
growing number of Android tablet users
we're all about quality here at Android
developer relations so we've also
released these core app quality
guidelines a checklist for your release
process that will ensure your apps
delight rather than disappoint continue
our tablet theme this week Nick roman
and adam talked responsive design in
Android design in action if designing
for tablets sounds like a lot of hard
work for an undetermined gain check out
these developer stories detailing how
mint com TinyCo and Instapaper took
advantage of the tablet opportunity we
spoke to the development teams behind
all three apps on last Thursday's
develop a strike back check out the
youtube video to learn how these
developers overcame the challenges to
build successful tablet apps on last
friday's app clinic we once again tried
to review video play apps cynics player
MX player and dice player sadly the
sheer overwhelming anticipation of this
long-awaited broadcast resulted in an
unprecedented demand from viewers tuning
in live which may or may not have caused
YouTube service to spontaneously combust
it was only after we've completed our
greatest ever live performance that we
realized that not only had we not been
broadcasting we hadn't been recording
either determined never to be defeated
we will be trying this one more time
broadcasting at the special one-off
bonus time of 1130 a.m. pacific time
this tuesday meanwhile undeterred by our
repeated failures Nick Roman and Adam
will be broadcasting the UX makeover on
two of the video players we seem
entirely unable to review live on the
App clinic on this week's Android design
in action then on Friday in and I will
once again tempt fate and the gods
themselves as we attempt to broadcast
the app clinic on Friday morning this
week looking at shopping apps
after the YouTube servers were brought
back to life last Friday even the
indomitable Dan Galpin for the Friday
games review dan will be back again this
Friday and with an as-yet undetermined
sidekick for another episode of the
Friday games review as always you can
catch our weekly office hours in London
Mountain View and Sydney and as always
you can find all of last week's shows
and the schedule for this week at Google
developers live that's
developers.google.com/live / android in
breaking news this week the long awaited
and much anticipated new Google Play
Developer console was released today for
everyone's app analysis and publishing
pleasure you can log in and check it out
right now or check out the post on the
Android developer blog to find out more
details before taking the plunge in
other developer news last week saw the
launch of free trial periods for in-app
subscriptions that's all in Android
development news this week as always we
look forward to you joining us for our
many live shows and remember before you
came into my life I missed you so bad my
name is reto Meier thanks for watching